I've never had anything paranormal and I
love the X Files I know I've never had
anything paranormal happen to me I mean
when I was in [__] uh I don't think
you would notice it if you were because
you'd be on your phone I I I show the
photo you'd be candy crushing if there
was like a a ship hovering no no no no
no I want I want to show you a photo
that was like very paranormal that
happened to me the other day right this
let me see me
see so can I tell you what text I got
what is send you hang on
[__] this is the text I got from Bobby
paranormal dude I'm sleeping here you
[__] the bed no no I'm sleeping I I'm D
I'm drowsy yeah right I hear these see
the lights like it was like a [__]
circular lights right then a beam of
light went into my [__] room dude
right I see a little gray dude he's like
eat which means I think I have to take a
[__] so you mean an alien [__] in your
bed yeah I do and then [__] was was [__]
on you I woke up and there was [__] all
underneath me debunk debunk debunk
because on September 14th at 4:23 p.m.
you said I have a stomach bug I said oh
no MythBusters the bun and then um I'm
going to go with that over the alien
[__] in your bed see then how come I
went with your [__] time traveler guy
you didn't do here's I have a question
though because you had a stomach bug
dude I know I a question I told just saw
the lights and the spinning things you
yeah and you didn't even go with me and
I went with you with your glitchy 1920s
man that's not right well did the light
really come down yeah it was a light I
little the [__] on but I was frozen I
couldn't right and he he rolled me over
too and he took a [__] right where I was
sleeping then he put me my body back on
the [__] right then I went back to sleep
I opened up and I was like oh my God a
little gray just in my [__] bed dude
nope can I tell I'm debunking this right
now okay don't don't debunk it I said he
said I have a stomach bug I said oh no
how bad are the Poes and then you didn't
send me a still shot you sent me a live
photograph of two different angles one
of your black underwear and then one of
your white sheet Ali also that that
underwear isn't black what is it it's
white and then it was
white but Gil look how it's live oh [__]
oh my God and then and then you
said you know and then you said I [__]
my pants while I was asleep last night
oh the alien told you that and then the
alien typed it they typed he typed it
with his long phone he doesn't even he
doesn't he could just do with his
thoughts yeah he kinetically did it you
understand my predic 100% you understand
what I went through to which I to which
I replied oh your signature move to
which you replied
yep why is that a signature move I said
oh your signature move and you said yep
wait a minute can I ask you a question I
ask a question here yeah yeah signature
is this have you [__] the bed on a numer
like numerous occasion I've never done
not necessarily the bed but like the
back seat of his car back seat of my car
and like multiple other like places in
Al I don't believe he did in the
backseat of his car that was the alien
that was the
alien who would do that on the freeway
on the 101 maybe there's an alien that
just sets you up to [__]
maybe there's just an alien that just
every time you yeah I know dude that's
what it is dude do you remember when you
[__] no right you black out I black out
because the aliens they no they know how
to wipe it clean like men in
black or maybe they got to hold some of
the Bill Cosby
stuff maybe Bill Cosby's an alien I mean
yeah who likes jelly wooding Pops that
much anyway yeah I pooed the pant I ped
the I ped the bed and um we had to pay
the hotel a lot because when it seeps
through oh it was a hotel it was at a
hotel oh man so when it seeps through
the the actual sheets and stuff and it
gets into the FR you know mattress bi
Hazard yeah they're like we got to buy a
whole new bed so that's like a couple of
grand right there you know no it's a
couple hundred 500 it was $600 biohazard
for sure wait that was a hotel bed yeah
how did you tell them like how was that
conversation ago well you know I have
car loss and because I was on the road
with Andrew oh so you have people
working for you so I called Carl dude
I'm sure that's listen here dude you
should have told him the alien story I'm
sure that's not uncommon because of like
babies and who are sick diarrhea